every equation every polynomial it's
just find the roots of unity right there
things like I rubbed it off like Zen
cubed equals one right or Zed to the
eight equals one or sent to that any
integer value I should say any positive
integer values okay so I'm gonna write
those they're all in the form Z to the N
equals 1/4 and being a jump okay now you
remember right one of the algebraic
tricks we played with this guy where you
said hey I can rewrite that I can
rewrite that with everything on the left
hand side I can say it is and that's
awesome because I can factorize that
thing right so I can work with it I
don't need to deal with moduli or
arguments anything like that I can do
with it in purely retained you before
and that was really cool and then I
showed you this right which by the way
is just a scale to the fifth division
all this right roots of unity really
helps you understand everything and we
said hold on
that's not sort of cool right in fact I
can only factorize it at the moment for
82 and N equals three right that's a bit
of pain except for the fact that you can
factorize it I want you to write down
this factorization for some Zant squared
take away one what's the factorization
difference of squares right yes okay and
then zared cubed difference of cubes is
one since with same opposite always
positive you care of that for me okay
now you have a look at this with me
right mathematicians are always such a
bad yeah always looking for patterns
clearly there's a pattern happening here
right I wonder if we could guess hmm
let's try something okay let's try this
and if I wanted to try to get to the
next power what might you expect we
might get it why don't we put it another
power in yeah and let's just see what
happens okay and this is not that hard
to do Zen times all of these guys right
it's gonna be excuse me said to the four
is that cute said squared what's in
what's all bye Jen and then oh what'd
you subtract and I'm gonna write up
underneath because it'll make me up the
parallel more amused is this and this
and this and this right it's all of
these guys right so this is all gonna
cancel here and you're just gonna be
left sure enough with this that's kind
of sweet right
what that's just like a proof by example
which is not a proof okay I've got a
couple other three cases where it works
but can I prove it
can I prove it for all cases which is
what I actually want okay now you can
see the business end of all of these
factorizations is really this guy right
each time because there's an take away
one it's the same every single time by
the way does it take mine is the same
every single time what does that mean
about the roots of this equation
it means Z equals 1 is always a solution
which you just told me based on this
remember that's like we were drawing all
of them right you said yeah I'm always
going to get one always one always one
and that's why this always appears every
time yes it's a minus 1 the grid itself
is 1
but the factorization is that might as
one
oh you're talking about if im doin's it
the end plus ones that we're talking
about yes okay yes but I'm not gonna
worry about it because that's not an
actual community I just did it to
demonstrate the actual geometry oh okay
now look carefully at those things I've
underlined in green you look carefully
at them hmm
yeah they're all they're all
everything's positive right I noticed as
well what gets added on each time is
that between the terms it's a common
ratio between the test if only I had
some mathematics that could deal with
adding up things when there was always a
common ratio wait I do because this
isn't GP it's always a GP right okay now
my question is what kind of GP is it
right let's write it in a form that's a
little more GP type I could say it
always starts with one I'm gonna go
reverse order it always goes to said and
then Zed squared that's three times
that's enough what's the last term now
in the real sense it doesn't matter okay
but for the context of what I'm dealing
with see how about to hear Henry's own
is anyone there don't even finish it
approximately at three and then a two a
four and then is three I'm gonna go to
minus one okay yeah this is a GP what's
the first term one wants to call the
ratio Zed what's the number of terms
right there are n terms right sir by
definition the sum of this thing is a a
cluster times the common ratio to the
power of the number of terms there are
take away one divided by the common
ratio take away one right oh snap you
multiply both sides by zip take away one
and there is your magic factorization in
like barely two lines okay now that's a
really important result because every
time you're dealing with roots of unity
which is what you're going to look at in
a second half by 1.5 I think you're
gonna have to deal with an equation like
this which needs to be factored on it
and now you can factorize for any powers